Hãy mấy hai trong bà báo hai giòn quý Surreal giống hình tin chính trị cấp cao tại Trung Đông Thilot.
Mí mong Moniz Real sớm kết thúc chính xí quần sử nhằm bệnh i Rang trong khoảng 1 tôn tới,
cho bất cả những có chính tần lòng ngày xin bột kéo sài.
Cô thế, gây tất động thúc cực lĩnh thị trường nâng lượng và kinh tế thuanc cầu.
Theo các mồn tin này, VIA Israel College in se kiện này là một thành công quần sự đáng cạnh,
và đang đánh giá các bước đi tiếp theo.
Cô thuy điểm mấy đứa cho là đại chức thận kiếm hoặc tiến công bộ bình hạnh trế Cuys Surreal vào miền Nam Li Băng.
Đông thơi cho phép mở giống quý mồ chính sĩ, nếu tình hình thử điện đại hỏi,
cho đó, Washington từ đặc biệt thời hạn nghĩ yêu cầu Háp Bolan sài sáp,
theo thoại thuận giống bản đàn được vào quái năm hành in không tra mít il,
lượng phòng VIA Israel trong báo với đình thị bộ bình này đã tìm xong hơn,
và miền Nam Li Băng và đã tìm hành như của đu tếc nhằm bật cơ sở hạ tân của lực lượng rát quan,
đơn vị tinh hợi thu kế Bolan, không còn Israel cũng tiến hành có được thương kế Cuys mua lớn tại miền Nam Li Băng,
và miên số khu vật cả thủ đồ bay đốt.
Theo dưới quan sát, dù Israel đã gây thiết hại cho các lực lượng đối địch.
Cái nhóm như Ebola vẫn tiếp tục dí trị hoàn đầu,
khiến quý cơ căng thẳng khu vật tiếp tục kếm sài.